well hello there whatever sons are
creepy how's it going friends my name is
Peter Pan that's right that's me today
I'm going to do what no other man has
ever dared to do play video games in VR
horror games yes doing this for you
Bruce
I'm a little scared I'm a little shaky
I'm all sweaty but that's alright the
ladies like it please keep watching okay
here we go
oh [ __ ] I got a gut press shoot to start
oh my god I'm out in the open
what am I gonna do well I got a try what
about this what about this oh that one
tingles a little bit cuz it vibrates
what about this oh this is how you shoot
hey oh [ __ ] it's starting what the [ __ ]
oh god oh god I see them take this oh
god it's not working
take that
yeah how do I miss who's that that when
you end where no matter what okay guys
careful oh you want some suck my [ __ ]
yeah come at me come [ __ ] at me hey
guess what you're [ __ ] dead
yeah that's right that's right you can't
[ __ ] with the booty pop [ __ ] yeah okay
yeah that's right
what you gonna do huh I call this one
these nuts
ah [ __ ] you I'm the [ __ ] King yeah
subtle you got game is that Oh laser
sight that's [ __ ] good explosive ammo
that's [ __ ] bad-ass bigger clips do I
think I need a bigger clips it's the
side it's [ __ ] done
nah Jack a lot of pizza okay
yeah well continue what you want but
they're bigger now well guess what
so am i hey guess what oh I don't like
that okay said the big ones they charge
once you shot him
Oh God
oh god it's getting [ __ ] intense okay
that's right
Oh what
that's [ __ ] in real life never
happened I know how to conserve ammo
it's one of my top features let's go do
I look like I'm [ __ ] to you huh
do I look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] do I look
like I've never hold a gun before way to
here we go
I look so [ __ ] cool right now oh I'm
just checking my phone whatever it's not
a big deal whatever excuse me were you
saying something
that was [ __ ] cool y'all want some
you all know me still same og okay Jesus
that was [ __ ] close what's your name
[ __ ] that's what's your name is that
say that say you want somebody's going
somewhere that's too bad only from March
[ __ ] what was that oh my [ __ ] god
what is that guys I'm scared
what is Sam
excuse me while I reload my gentleman
Jesus oh god they're getting too many
[ __ ] they're everywhere
daddy
oh [ __ ]
ah I'm dying
okay I'm out of ammo oh god please
forgive
alright I'm alive that was intense
that was [ __ ] cool I felt like a
badass Vieira's here guys it's [ __ ]
beautiful if you want more videos please
leave a like I really hope you enjoyed
this video thanks for watching and as
always stay awesome bros there's the
[ __ ] king I swear to God excuse me
[ __ ]
yeah what's good that's right